In "Love Works," I write about seven timeless principles for effective leaders.
We actually defined "love" and how to use it in the workplace.
Now, in my thirty years experience, most recently as CEO of Saab North America and CEO of Herschend Entertainment,...
...I've found that we're all very quick as leaders to talk about love and our personal lives,...
...but we're loathe to talk about it in the workplace.
It's because I think we see it as soft.
We see it as an emotion.
But in "Love Works," we show that it's a verb.
It's how you behave.
It's not how you feel,...
...and it also gets the very best results out of those you lead...
...because it builds healthy relationships that brings out the very best in people...
...and makes them incredibly loyal employees.
By reading "Love Works," you'll find that you don't have to leave your heart at home.
You can bring it to work,...
...and you can also get great results while you're doing it.
You'll learn to invest in your company by investing in the relationships of those you work with as the leader.